Hello, viewer. It is Pastry Week.
What's your favourite pastry, Noel?
I love a flaky pastry, Matt.
Mmm. Me too. Like this fella here.
[in husky voice] Mate,
I can't pay you back this week,
something's come up. Also, I know
I said I'd give you a lift to the airport,
but it's not gonna work out.
[both] So flaky.
Welcome to the Great British Baking Show.
[Matt] Now…
-I want to see baking nirvana.
-…it's the quarter-final.
-Should have paid attention.
-…and Pastry Week.
[Sandro] Oh, my God.
[Matt] The final five
face a super sweet signature…
I don't wanna present a raw pastry.
…and get on a roll
with a tricky technical.
-Manga-tout.
-Mangay-toot?
Whoo, that's got confusing.
-[Matt] It's back to school for some…
-Too much maths!
…with a spectacular storybook showstopper.
[Janusz] Ahhh! That's hot.
-[Matt] Who'll have a fairy-tale ending?
-Shame it wasn't an ice cream competition.
[Matt] And for whom is this chapter
about to come to a close?
It is just mind-blowing right now.
[opening theme music playing]
[indistinct chatter]
[Syabira] I can't believe it.
I reached the quarter-final.
It's exciting times.
-[Abdul] Good luck.
-[Maxy] You too.
You, best of luck, man.
It is just mind-blowing right now.
I mean, I can't believe I'm here.
I'm now surrounded by all Star Bakers.
We don't know who's leaving.
Could be anyone. But there's no weak link.
Quarter-finals!
Quarter-finals, quarter-finals. Yeah.
I think now, this is the stage
that any mistake can eliminate you.
No room for a bad bake now.
Bakers, welcome back
to the tent for Pastry Week.
Er, Noel, what immediately springs to mind
when I say the word "party"?
Oh.
Studio 54, 1977,
Bianca Jagger comes in on a white horse.
Andy Warhol's there
supping prosecco
out of Evel Knievel's chest wig.
That's right, vol-au-vents.
For your quarter-final
signature challenge,
the judges would like you each
to bake a batch of 12 sweet vol-au-vents.
Your vol-au-vents should be made
from beautiful, flaky rough puff pastry
and filled with a sweet
mouth-watering filling of your choice.
You have two minutes
and one hour and 58 minutes.
-On your marks…
-[Matt] Get set…
[both] Vol-au-vents.
I've never heard of vol-au-vents before.
It's just, like, party food
you get from the supermarket.
Vol-au-vent is something so from '70s.
It's Pastry Week. We've given the bakers
two hours to produce sweet vol-au-vents.
Traditionally, we think vol-au-vent,
we think savoury.
But we've put a slight twist on it.
And they're non-savoury.
This is sweet vol-au-vent,
another new level.
Puff pastry lends itself
to either sweet or savoury.
The key thing with this challenge
is getting that lamination
and getting that beautiful golden colour
and crisp on the vol-au-vent itself.
[Prue] The filling must pack a punch.
It can be anything they like.
It needs to be both light,
so they don't spoil
the flakiness of the pastry,
but they need to be flavourful.
It's the quarter-final
and we're expecting nothing but perfection
from our five amazing bakers.
[Abdul] I think with my signatures,
usually I'm calm,
then again, things can still go wrong.
I mean, er, you never know.
It is the tent after all.
Because this is the quarter-final,
Paul and I will be really ruthless.
I mean,
we have to have everything perfect.
I think at this time in the competition,
any little mistake will be picked on.
We'll see.
-Syabira, hello.
-Hello, hi.
-Good morning.
-Good morning. Star Baker last week.
[chuckles] It's in the past now.
-It's clean slate this week.
-[Paul and Prue] Again.
Tell us about your vol-au-vent.
It's called Citrus Dreams vol-au-vent.
So, a pastry case and then inside,
it's gonna be orange and mandarin
and, erm, I put a little bit hint
of clove and cardamom
to enhance the flavour
of the orange itself.
What's in the vol-au-vent?
Have you got a crème pat or--
It's a orange and mandarin cream cheese.
Orange and-- Oh, right, okay.
[Matt] Enhanced with orange liqueur,
Syabira is hoping
the citrus cream cheese-filled vol-au-vent
will be enough to maintain
her strong run in the competition,
landing her Star Baker
for a third week running.
-Sounds good.
-Are you comfortable with this?
-I hope so.
-Do you wanna be in the semifinal?
-Course she does.
-Yes. I want to.
-How much?
-Very much.
-[all laughing]
-Honestly, very much.
-Good luck.
-Good luck, Syabira.
Maybe they expect
something more like crème pat,
but I tried with the custard,
it's not enough to enhance the flavour,
so I hope I'm making the right decision.
[Matt] Yet to match Syabira's success…
I just lose track of time
and then, at the end, I start panicking.
…Abdul is keen to impress
with his take on the classic vol-au-vent.
My vol-au-vents,
I… I don't have much rise on them
because that's how I prefer them.
Because if I get too much rise,
they go wonky.
-Hi, Abdul.
-[Abdul] Hello.
Hello, Abdul. I don't want to spook you,
but you are the only baker
who hasn't had Star Baker.
[laughs] Yes, I know. Yes.
-So what about doing it today?
-No pressure. [laughs]
I will try.
Each week I've been giving my best.
What I find
always helps you with your confidence
is someone reminding you
that you haven't been Star Baker… [laughs]
-…at the beginning of the day.
-Yeah.
I'm prodding him. I want him to do it.
[Matt] Abdul's path to success
lies with vol-au-vent dipped in chocolate
topped with strawberries
and filled with a berry compote
and coconut crème pat.
I heard that Paul
just likes the feel
of coconut on his feet.
So he grates up coconuts,
puts it on his carpet,
and his lovely fake-tanned feet,
just crunching away on coconut shavings.
-It's an image, innit?
-It is. It is.
Take that with you to the semifinal.
[laughs]
[Matt] Rough puff pastry
consists of four simple ingredients.
So this is just flour,
water, salt, and… butter.
[Matt] And one baker keen to keep
his flavours in the same vein is Janusz.
Strawberries and cream. You know,
a classic one, so hopefully they like it.
-Janusz.
-[Janusz] Hello.
-[Paul] Hello.
-Hello. Tell us about your vol-au-vent.
I've decided to make,
basically, strawberries and cream.
Is it whipped cream inside or--
Er, I'll make crème pat,
that holds strawberries much better.
[Matt] Janusz will fill
each rough puff vol-au-vent
with fresh strawberries
covered in a summer fruit liqueur glaze.
He plans to put a twist
on the classic combination
by replacing the more traditional
cream base with custard.
So you've got crème pat cream
and strawberries.
-Crème pat and strawberries.
-[Paul] Okay.
-No cream.
-[Janusz] No cream.
Okay, and how will you
make sure your crème pat's not gloopy?
I'll try it, if it's gloopy,
I'll replace it with whipped cream.
[laughter]
-Or…
-[Janusz] I've got a plan for it.
If it's gloopy, it'll be whipped cream,
you'll know it was gloopy.
The plan is to grate some frozen butter
and use that for the lamination.
[Matt] The key to successful lamination…
You don't want
the butter to be soft at all.
You want it to stay cold.
…lies in keeping the layers
of pastry and butter as cool as possible.
I'm gonna grate my frozen butter.
It looks like cheese.
Cold, cold, cold,
and never melt your butter.
[Matt] Failure to do so
means the butter will ooze out,
the layers will be lost
and the vol-au-vents will have no rise.
[Janusz] They go to the freezer now.
[Matt] But one baker
is throwing caution to the wind.
Everyone else is using cold butter.
I actually need room-temperature butter.
Still want chunks of butter.
[Matt] Maxy plans to fill
her experimental vol-au-vent
with Chantilly cream
laced with gooseberry and cloudberry jam.
She's hoping to avoid any butter leaks
by selecting a robust pastry.
I've used strong bread flour
and I used room-temperature butter
which I broke up into pieces.
-You used room-temperature, popped it in…
-[Maxy] Yeah.
…folded it initially
and popped them in the fridge.
Yep. And I used ice-cold water as well.
-And how many folds did you give it?
-[Maxy] Three.
-Three?
-[Maxy] Yeah.
Three singles or three book?
-Three doubles. Yeah.
-[Prue] Three double.
Okay.
[Matt] While still keeping
his pastry cold,
Sandro is putting
a different twist on his dough.
I'm just really coating this with sugar.
So there's a lot of caramelisation.
[Matt] He's also hoping
some inside knowledge
will give him the upper hand.
So I'm making
a key lime cheesecake vol-au-vent.
I chose these flavours
because I want to get a handshake.
[laughs]
And Paul loves…
That's his favourite dessert,
is key lime pie.
[Matt] Sandro aims to get Paul on side
with his version
of the classic key lime pie
using a lime crème pat,
lime jam and ginger biscuits,
but as it's his favourite,
Paul's expectations are sky-high.
Are you using key limes
or are you using Persians?
I'm using limes.
-[laughter]
-Green ones.
-[Prue] Any limes.
-Oh, I like the key limes.
-Oh.
-[laughs]
Bakers, you are halfway through!
[Syabira] It's getting soft now,
so I'm gonna quickly
pop it back in the freezer.
I'm gonna allow it to chill again.
Refrigerate it for 20 minutes
and then… And then it's time to bake.
[Matt] As their pastry chills,
the bakers now have the opportunity
to make a start on their fillings.
My pastry is chilling.
I'm making my crème pat.
I'll start making custard.
I'm putting in coconut extract,
which should enhance that flavour.
[Maxy] I've got two jams to make.
Gooseberry and cloudberry.
[Syabira] Mandarin cordial orange zest,
a bit of clove and cardamom,
cream cheese and whipping cream.
I'm just making cream
in case my custard is gloopy.
[chuckles]
Lime jam.
I mean, it tastes like lime.
It's thick how I want it to be. [chuckles]
-[Noel] Hello.
-Hi.
How's it going?
Want me to touch your stuff?
-You can touch if you want.
-What's that for?
-Doing egg wash on my--
-Egg wash.
-Yeah.
-I egg washed a priest once.
-What?
-He wasn't looking.
A bust-up, just egg washed his legs.
-Came out lovely, all crispy.
-Oh, gosh.
-Gone weird, innit?
-Yes. [laughs]
[coughs] That is lime.
[spoon clatters]
That is definitely lime.
[Matt] In creating their vol-au-vents…
Now I'm gonna roll it
and do the shells that I want.
…speed is of the essence…
[Maxy] I'm gonna
roll this out into a rectangle.
[Matt] …as the shells must be assembled
and baked before the temperature
of the pastry rises and butter melts.
[Syabira] It has to be neat,
but at the same time,
not to try and melt the butter too much.
[Sandro] Base layers, nice and thin.
I'm gonna have 12 bottoms
and then 24 tops.
[Matt] A typical vol-au-vent shell
is formed by layering
hollow circles of pastry into a tower.
But once again, Maxy has other ideas.
[Maxy] They are squares.
I'm going for a square-shaped vol-au-vent.
[Janusz] Maxy.
-Yes, darl.
-Tell me if it's gloopy.
-You be the judge.
-Okay.
It's on the thicker side.
If you've got cream, put some cream in it.
-Whipped cream.
-Hmm.
Okay, I will.
Bit of egg wash after egg wash. Ha!
Then it's going straight into the oven.
How long do we have?
Bakers, you have half an hour left.
Exactly what I thought.
All this talk about handshakes.
"Have you had a handshake?"
I mean, I've never had a handshake.
-What, in your life?
-No.
-Would you like one?
-Yeah.
-How did that feel?
-Oh, that's nice.
-Is it all right?
-Yeah.
The difference is
Hollywood's palms are very hairy.
I know. He makes me
comb the hair on his hands sometimes.
[laughs]
They need to be baked
for about 20 minutes.
I've put about ten to 15 minutes.
So it's 190 degree.
-[timer beeps]
-[Janusz] 14 to 15 minutes.
[Maxy] Don't know
what will happen in the oven.
[chuckles] I don't want
to keep my hopes up too high.
[Sandro gasps]
It's not been on, erm…
My oven's not been on. [sighs]
The oven wasn't hot.
I forgot to press the… the "on" button.
So… could still work out.
And it could be an absolute fail today.
Just give me the custard.
[Matt] With assembly time at a premium…
[Janusz] It's only two hours,
we're going to struggle.
Vol-au-vent, brown.
[chuckles] Why are they not browning?
[Matt] …it's essential they have
any other elements prepared.
I'll just prep everything.
I'm just chucking in
my little strawberries
into my elderflower syrup.
Quick and easy to make.
It'll be a tight one. As per usual.
[Sandro] This biscuit
is not the most important thing,
so if they keep their shape, it's fine.
I find out I cannot make custard.
So there we are.
I moved on to make
my summer fruit punch glaze.
[Syabira] This is the pecan praline
with orange zest.
Important thing is this berry
and the custard cools down fairly enough
before I put it in the shell
or else the shell goes all soggy.
I couldn't be a baker,
'cause I don't like the early starts.
-I'm the same.
-[Matt] Are you?
-I'm not a morning person.
-What time do you go to bed?
My usual time is about 1:30
to, er, two o'clock.
-Oh, really? When do you wake up?
-Yes.
And I wake up
around, erm, 9:00, 9:30, 10:00?
I think you should probably go
and get yourself checked out
'cause you might actually be a teenager.
[laughing] I haven't got…
[Syabira breathes deeply]
I think it's cooked.
[Sandro] Could be
the worst vol-au-vents I've made.
[Maxy chuckling] They're not golden yet.
And they're really leaning.
I think it's done
'cause I can see the bottom is golden.
-[Janusz] If it is, remove them.
-[Syabira] All right, I'll take it out.
[Abdul] The butter is leaking.
It's the first time I'm seeing it leaking.
[Janusz] They're okay. They're laminated.
Should be fine,
they go to the freezer now.
[Syabira] It's cooked.
I'd say…
five more minutes,
but that's cutting it short.
I don't wanna present a raw pastry.
[laughing nervously] Oh, God.
Matthew, if you're a good boy
and you do the time call well,
you can have a chocolate.
Bakers, you have 15 minutes.
There you go. Good boy.
[Maxy] Fifteen minutes and they're
not even out the oven. [laughs]
They look terrible.
They're all wonky.
[Sandro] The butter's just oozing out.
Everything is lopsided.
There's not even one perfect one.
[groaning] Er…
[gasping]
I'm just piping some cream
onto my vol-au-vents.
It's just whipped cream.
I think custard worked out
in my head, but not in real life.
I'm going to sprinkle some
praline at the bottom.
'Cause it's going to sit
at room temperature for a while.
I'm just taking out the middle bit now
so I can fill it with the custard.
[Sandro] They look
like Yorkshire puddings, they do.
-Look at this business--
-Mess.
-[Noel] Are they a bit flat?
-I'm not happy at all.
-They all--
-What's with these trousers today?
Thought I'd wear leather trousers,
so it's easier to clean.
Show Prue your trousers, she'll forget
about the height of your vol-au-vents.
[laughing] Good luck.
I'll sit there like that
with my vol-au-vents.
-Handshake from me.
-[both laughing]
You know what?
I'm just gonna take 'em out.
Got no choice.
[sighs] What a disaster, eh?
Bakers, you have five minutes left.
-[sighs]
-[exhales]
[Sandro] How great do these look?
[Syabira] I am just gonna pipe it in.
[Maxy] I don't know
if I can even put the cream in.
I can't believe this, honestly.
[Sandro] Full of ginger. I can smell it.
[gasps] I'm pushing myself
and I'm breaking my shells.
[Sandro] 'Cause it's warm,
it's just too liquidy.
It's not good.
It's really, really, really, not good.
[groaning] Oh, my God.
[Janusz] Hopefully, it will be perfect,
because if you're doing classics,
you cannot really go wrong on them.
[sighs in exasperation] Stress.
This is so risky. [scoffs]
Just the final bits left,
so just pushing myself.
[inhales deeply]
Breathe, breathe, breathe.
Bakers, your time is up.
-Please step away from your bakes.
-[laughs nervously]
[Abdul] Bit messy.
[inhales deeply] Why?
[Janusz] Maxy, it's okay.
[Matt] It's judgement time
for the bakers' sweet vol-au-vents.
Not even a quarter of the height
-I expect them to be.
-Mmm-hmm.
Er, so they are very flat and very pale.
The butter leaked as well.
This is the first time it happened.
[Paul] There's no butter on there.
It's bone dry.
It's okay.
The chocolate solidified round the side.
It's so pale and so thin.
It's almost just a sheet of puff pastry
-with bits on top.
-Okay.
I think you've got
too many flavours in there.
Because there are too many,
you can't taste anything individually.
And it's a bit murky.
-Bit under-baked and too thin.
-And too complicated. Poor Abdul.
[laughs] That's okay.
Could we think
of something nice to say? [laughs]
-Welcome to the quarter-final.
-Yeah.
[all laughing]
-Thank you.
-[Abdul] Thank you.
They're all over the place.
[Prue] We didn't ask
for a Leaning Tower of Pisa,
[Paul] You've got a burnt biscuit
sitting on top of quite a dark,
very low vol-au-vent.
The flavour is amazing,
but it needs to be lighter.
Vol-au-vents should be light and airy.
-It melts in the mouth.
-[Sandro] Yeah.
Pastry's over-baked.
But I think the flavour is fantastic.
I don't agree
that the ginger biscuit's burnt.
That's burnt.
What do you think?
-I think it looks over-baked.
-Thank you.
Here am I trying to help you, Sandro.
[all laughing]
-He's brutal today, eh?
-He is brutal today.
Quite attractive,
I like what you've done
with the glazed strawberries on top.
They're uneven.
Probably needed a bit longer in the oven.
They're a little pale for a vol-au-vent.
How did you get on with the crème pat?
-What crème pat?
It never happened.
-I take it gloopy.
-It never happened. [laughs]
[Prue] So what we have is crème Chantilly?
[Janusz] Whipped cream.
Strawberries and cream.
[Prue] This is really still raw inside.
It's a bit boring because all there is
is cream and strawberry
and a pretty dry vol-au-vent.
[sighs] It's a shame, actually,
the crème pat would have worked
if you'd put cream with it.
-Thank you.
[sighing] My vol-au-vents
decided to go
for a dance in the oven, erm…
They… They're…
You know, they're all over the place.
[laughs nervously]
Bit irregular in size.
Bit irregular on height,
a bit irregular on colour.
-Not very appealing to look at.
-I know.
A bit dry. And quite flat.
-Yeah, I--
-Expected them to be much higher.
Square's quite difficult to do.
Round is easier,
which is why most vol-au-vents are round.
I think they needed longer bake time.
-Were you rushed for time at the end?
-I was.
[Paul] It's raw at the bottom here.
Really thick band of raw--
-[Prue] Really under-baked, isn't it?
-[Maxy sighs] Sorry.
I had a terrible time making them, so…
Oddly, I didn't think
both jams would work, but they do.
Gooseberry and cloudberry are delicious.
Unfortunately, you get
that overriding flavour of raw pastry
down at the bottom.
-Thanks, Maxy.
-Thank you. Okay.
[whispering] They like
the flavours, though.
Yeah, I knew they were going to be raw.
Oh, gosh.
I like the look of them,
I think they look quite authentic.
And all pretty much the same size as well.
Nice height. You trapped the butter inside
'cause you get the height
without lamination on the outside.
[Prue] The pastry's just cooked through,
it's a little doughy in the middle.
Probably two minutes away
from being perfect.
-What did you put down at the bottom?
-The orange praline.
It's gone back to a liquid
'cause it's got liquid on top.
Which is nice.
I think the flavours are beautiful.
-I really do.
-This is a delicious vol-au-vent.
The custard inside is light.
And the pecan praline is just delicious.
-You've done a nice job with these.
-Thank you.
-[Paul] Thank you.
-Well done.
Thank you.
Paul says two minutes from perfect.
If I have those two minutes.
I don't. [laughs]
Paul says the rise should be four times.
That's a bit crazy.
The flavours were good,
but it's Pastry Week,
so I do have to be a bit worried,
seeing as I had an undercooked pastry,
[Janusz] Paul called it boring.
It's strawberries and cream.
You can't go wrong.
But at the same time,
I can understand why it's boring.
If it was just perfectly risen,
I would have got my handshake today.
[laughs sarcastically] I don't even
want it now. Now I don't want it. At all.
[birds chirping]
[Matt] The bakers have no idea
what they'll be asked to make
in the mystery
that is the technical challenge.
Bakers, it's time
for your technical challenge,
which today has been set by
Prue-lio Inglesias!
Oh, we love your music.
-Oh, so sexy.
-Yeah.
-Even better without the moustache.
-[Matt] Yeah. Agreed.
Will you give us
some words of advice, please?
Bakers, there are
29 ingredients in this recipe,
so please get the balance right.
[Noel] As ever, the technical challenge
will be judged blind.
So we'll have to ask Prue-lio Inglesias
and Paul Hollywood to leave the tent.
-[whispering] They'll probably kiss.
-[Matt] Yeah.
For your technical challenge,
Prue-lio would like you
to make eight spring rolls,
featuring a delicate pastry that have been
deep fried to crispy perfection.
And they must be served
alongside a dipping sauce.
You have one hour and 20 minutes.
-On your marks…
-Get set…
Bake.
Ay-ay-ay. What is this, mate?
[Syabira] Right. The deep fryer.
I am quite surprised with spring rolls,
I'm not gonna lie.
First time making them.
It's new thing to do.
My mom, she used to make them,
but I don't remember much, though.
Should have paid attention.
I'm trying to figure out what to do.
[laughs] I don't know.
[Paul] So, Prue, spring rolls.
I mean, I don't think many
people make spring rolls,
but I feel it's a great test.
After all, it is the quarter-final
and it's quite difficult.
The pastry's tricky.
And I think we'll have some of the bakers
struggling with huge great bubbles.
And those bubbles come
because the water's in the pastry.
We haven't told them how much water.
If it's too wet, the bubbles will be
huge and ugly and misshapen.
But they should be more like this one,
which is absolutely smooth.
It's a great challenge.
It's nice to have something savoury.
-[Prue] Isn't it?
-We have so much sweetness.
All crispy.
Nice thin pastry with a beautiful
breakdown of all that filling together.
You've got a bit of everything in there.
It's a great snack.
[mumbling]
Sorry, what did you say?
[chuckling]
It's easy for you to say, Prue.
[chuckling] Mmm!
The first part is
make a stiff dough and rest.
I just don't know
how much water to put in.
I'm literally just guessing.
Maybe one more tablespoon.
You have to not add a lot.
It's quite stiff.
[Matt] A stiff dough
is required for a smooth shell.
I think my dough is very stiff.
The same time, it's got a nice spring.
[Matt] If the bakers add too much water,
unsightly bubbles will appear when fried.
It says stiff dough.
But it is a bit smooth.
Maybe it's a bit too soft.
How is it meant to rest?
Are we meant to cover it or…
What do we do?
All right, "Soak the noodles
and wood ear mushrooms."
What even is that?
Wood ear mushrooms?
[Janusz] Perfect.
[Maxy] These mushrooms look so weird.
[Noel] Is this your mushrooms?
Yeah.
Do you ever go foraging?
A long time ago.
Did anyone go with you
or you just took it upon yourself?
Me and my neighbours.
You and your neighbours?
-I suppose it's big in Sweden?
-Yeah.
-They're more in touch with nature.
-Definitely.
Pretty much always naked
and eating mushrooms.
-Miss those times?
-Erm--
-The sort of mushroom nakeds?
-[both laugh]
Getting kidnapped by your neighbours
and going foraging.
I miss those times. [laughs]
If you tried that now,
wouldn't work out, I don't think.
-Not in Peckham.
-[laughs]
I don't even live in Peckham.
So then I need to cut
cabbage and manga-tout.
Mangay-toot?
Mang-toot?
Is this a mangay-toot?
"Cut into fine…" This must be mangay-toot.
I don't really do these kind of foods.
[Maxy] Okay, I need to cook these,
but it doesn't really say
how much of what to put in.
You need to figure out the proportions,
that was expected
on a technical this week.
So, that black mushroom
is very strong taste.
You don't want to put too much in it.
[Abdul gasps] Forgot about the mushrooms.
[chuckling]
Oh, they're massive, man!
I think I need to chop them.
-Bakers, you are halfway through.
-[thuds]
[sighs]
Gonna start panicking now.
[Abdul] I'm starting step number four.
"Knead the dough
and divide into eight equal pieces."
"Roll out one piece of the dough
to eight centimetres circle."
"Repeat with another piece of dough
so you have two eight centimetre circles."
"Sprinkle the top of one
of the circles of dough with cornflour."
"Then place the other one on top
and roll it to 22 centimetres."
Whoo, that's got confusing. Wow!
Too much maths!
This is like full speed
spring roll-making competition.
I don't know how people can
get this done in one hour and 20 minutes.
"Place the two circles of dough
in the pan and cook on both sides."
[Syabira] Right, quick.
"Fold the dough in half so that
you have two transparent wrappers."
Perfect, I can see my fingers.
So, now I need to trim
each wrapper into square shape.
I'm on step number seven,
er, which is,
"Assemble and seal the spring rolls."
[Matt] Paul and Prue demand sumptuous
spring rolls packed full of flavour.
The technique for filling
is put a good generous amount
so they've got a taste of everything.
Get things to taste
deliciousness-ness-ness-ness.
[Matt] If shortchanged…
I don't want too much of this.
…the dominant taste
will be the pastry shell.
Maxy, do you make
this sort of thing often?
-[Maxy] I buy this sort of thing often.
-Yeah.
When I saw we had
an hour and 20, I was like,
"I'll just go down the takeaway."
"I'd get some spring rolls,
I'd get a chow mein while I'm at it."
What's stopping you?
-We don't have that luxury.
-That's a shame.
Bakers, you have 15 minutes left.
[whistles]
[Maxy] I need to fry them.
[whimpers]
[Janusz] Bye-bye, babies.
[Matt] In order to achieve
the crisp golden brown shells
Paul and Prue expect…
[Sandro] Sounds like frying.
[Matt] …the oil temperature
needs to be hot enough…
That is 180 degree.
…they must be fried for long enough…
We need to cook for another,
maybe, three to four minutes really.
…and be monitored carefully.
Let's swap sides.
[Matt] But it's no mean feat…
Sauce. Sauce.
I'm multitasking.
…when the bakers have
dipping sauces to prepare.
List doesn't say anything
so we're gonna wing it.
I think it will be difficult
to get the right blend definitely.
Soy sauce.
Fish sauce.
Palm sugar.
Ah, this so stressful.
I'm gonna taste and then I'm gonna adjust.
Ugh!
[spoon clanks]
That is horrible!
Oh, bleurgh!
They're turning to the raw side.
Turn to the other side, dudes.
[Janusz] So, it's eight.
They're looking crispy.
Would you buy that?
I've already got a deep fat fryer.
No, not the…
[laughs]
That was a nice way of putting, "Erm, no."
Bakers, you have five minutes left.
Oh, my goodness.
This is crazy.
Come on, guys.
These are coming out.
Uh-oh. I just under-fried it,
but I don't think I have time.
[Janusz] Come on, time is very tight.
[Sandro] None of them cracked. Oh!
[exhales deeply]
Come on.
I think I made mine too small.
-[Abdul] Come on, buddy.
-I'm ready for this technical to be over.
Bakers, your time is up!
[sighs]
[Maxy] Oh, my God, they're tiny.
Please bring your spring rolls
down to the gingham table
and place them behind your photographs.
Mine are so small
compared to everyone else's.
-Oh, God!
-Doesn't matter.
[Matt] Paul and Prue are expecting
eight identical spring rolls
with crisp golden brown pastry,
a delicious filling,
and a perfectly-balanced dipping sauce.
[Paul] So, start with this one.
There's a lot of bubbles in this.
That means there's
too much water in the dough.
[Paul] And it's not been fried enough.
Still quite raw, you can see
how clear that one is.
It should've stayed
in there a little longer.
-[Paul] Have a look inside.
-[Prue] Filling looks quite good.
[Paul] Yeah, it looks busy, doesn't it?
The flavour's good.
Dipping sauce is nice and sharp as well.
It just needs to be deep fried for longer.
[Prue] Yeah. Right.
[Paul] Moving on. They're a bit dinky,
but they're quite crispy.
The issue is there's not
much filling, it's all pastry.
And because it's mostly pastry,
it's a bit stodgy.
[Paul] Mmm-hmm.
I mean, it tastes okay,
just not enough filling.
-[Prue] Yeah.
-[Paul] Okay.
Next one, let's have a look.
-Crispy.
-[Prue] Lovely crack when you cut it.
[Paul] But the air holes
are a little bit big,
so it's probably a little bit wet.
Lots of mushroom in there.
[Paul] There is, yeah.
-Mmm.
-There's a little bit too much mushroom.
[Prue] It's definitely
a mushroom spring roll.
Okay. Moving on, they're all
roughly all the same size.
The bubbles are there, but not
quite as big as some of the others.
Nice blend inside.
The actual mixture content is good.
[Prue] I like the crisp pastry very much.
Beautifully thin, that pastry,
and the dipping is nice.
-[Prue] Lovely.
-[Paul] Okay. Moving on to the last one.
Only seven, not eight.
It's a shame we're missing one.
[softly] What? I made eight.
These air holes are huge.
[Prue] It's a pity because
where it's crisp it's really nice.
The pastry is delicious and very crisp.
And the sauce is good,
but where's the eighth?
[Matt] Paul and Prue
will now rank the spring rolls
from last to first place.
In fifth place, we have this one.
Maxy, too small,
too much pastry, not enough filling.
Yeah.
Fourth, we have this one. Whose is this?
Syabira, not been fried enough.
In third place is this one.
Abdul, bit too much mushroom,
but they were good.
In second spot,
we have this one, whose is this?
Pretty good, but where was the eighth?
Deep fried eight, seven ended up
on the plate, don't know what happened.
[bakers chuckling]
Genuinely.
Who ate Janusz's spring roll?
-Probably me.
-[Noel laughs]
Well, that means,
in first place, we have Sandro.
The pastry was excellent.
Delicious and lovely dipping sauce.
Well done.
[laughing]
That's what my kid does. He's like, "Ah!"
Yeah, now that I've got
the tech win, it has evened me out,
and I'm just trying to secure my spot.
I made eight spring rolls
and there were seven.
Still came second. Not bad.
It's very tough competition at the moment,
other bakers are really good.
So, tomorrow I need to be more focused.
We are all just neck to neck literally.
It's too close to call between all of us.
Gonna make sure I have a good rest
and smash it tomorrow hopefully.
Hopefully. I hope I-- I hope I will.
[indistinct chatter]
[Matt] The bakers have just
one more pastry challenge…
-[Syabira] Good luck, guys.
-…in which to impress the judges.
Hello, bakers. Welcome back to the tent.
It's time for your pastry
showstopper challenge.
[Matt] Now, for your
showstopper this week,
Paul and Prue would like you each to bake
an incredible 3D pie scene
inspired by your favourite
childhood story or nursery rhyme.
Your scene can either be sweet or savoury,
but must consists of eight pies
shaped and beautifully decorated.
Hickory dickory dock,
you have four hours on the clock.
-On your marks…
-Get set…
Bake!
[sighs] Okay. I'm so scared!
I've got 12 pages
to my recipe for one bake.
[Sandro chuckles]
I've got a book for my one bake.
It is the quarter-final, so you've
gotta give it your absolute best.
The showstopper challenge our bakers
have to face is a storybook pie scene.
We want the bakers to create a scene
instantly recognisable when we look at it.
So, it could be any nursery rhyme,
any children's story,
it is down to the bakers,
but the star of this particular challenge
has to be the crust.
When I cut into the pie,
I wanna see a beautiful thin pastry
creating a beautiful buttery flavour
with a filling that packs a punch.
I know what's my favourite. Pork pie.
[Prue] Can the bakers make
a really good pastry
that properly holds their filling?
And that is all about
not getting the filling too wet,
which will make for a soggy bottom,
and not have it too stiff
so that it's too dry or hard.
[Paul] This is Pastry Week
and to be honest,
I'm not happy with what
they've created so far.
They should be doing better,
we've got five fantastic bakers.
There is no room for error.
If they just crack out
eight perfect pork pies,
I will not be impressed.
I want to see baking nirvana.
-Abdul. Good morning.
-Hello.
Tell us about your pie scene,
what are you doing?
Erm, so my pie scene is based
on the book Treasure Island.
And the curry that I'm bringing
is called khatte baingan,
which means, er, bittersweet aubergine.
[Matt] Inspired by his mum's recipe,
Abdul hopes to strike gold this week
with his Treasure Island theme.
He's making a selection
of sweet and savoury pies
depicting the island boat
and chest in meticulous detail.
So the pie scene itself
will have an island,
er, that will be made out of apple
and blackberry crumble tart.
-This sounds great.
-It sounds good.
The idea of the apple as the island,
and the curry as the ship.
-Yes.
-What pastry is that sitting in?
So the pastry, I'm making
two types of pastry,
a sweet shortcrust and a shortcrust.
-[Prue] Sounds good.
-Thank you.
Thank you, guys. Thank you.
[Matt] The bakers can use
whichever pastry they wish
when creating their fairy-tale bakes.
Get this into a breadcrumby
sweets pastry.
[whirring rhythmically]
[Matt] Selecting the correct type
of pastry and filling is crucial,
as they need to take into account
both flavour and structural integrity.
Initially, I'm making a filo pastry,
but that is not sturdy enough.
So this is the hot oil pastry.
It's like hot water crust, but hot oil.
-[Paul] Good morning.
-Hello.
[Matt] Hello.
Tell us about your pie scene.
I am making Jack and the Beanstalk today.
I admired Jack during my childhood
'cause he could climb up
this very tall beanstalk, up to the sky.
And I was little at that point,
and I can see the coconut tree
actually very high up to the sky.
-So… so I tried to--
-So this is Jack and the coconut tree.
[laughs] Jack and the coconut tree
in Malaysia.
[Matt] And just like the protagonist
in her story, Syabira is aspiring
to reach the top spot again this week
with her elaborate two-tiered structure,
complete with Jack, a giant, his castle,
and, of course, the beanstalk,
all fashioned using
a unique Malaysian pastry.
-[Paul] Your filling is?
-[Syabira] Chicken rendang filling.
It's a very traditional filling
I really like, I usually eat it with rice.
-You can put rice and that into a pastry?
-Too much carbs.
-Don't want that on your calorie counter.
-No, I really do.
Is it? I never know people
put rice in a pie. [laughs]
Look forward to it,
'cause these flavours sound amazing.
-Thank you.
-[Paul] Good luck, thank you.
[Matt] As well as ensuring
the pastry's fit for purpose,
the bakers must carefully choose
what goes inside their pies.
For the chana dal,
I'm basically gonna cook it in water,
because it takes about
40 minutes for it to go soft.
The aubergine and the potatoes
are kind of the main aspect of it.
[Matt] And it seems curry is a hot choice
of filling in the tent today.
I am using home flavours.
Spicy chicken, which is a recipe that
has been passed down
from my mum and my grandma.
[Matt] Maxy is hoping to bounce back
from her disappointing signature
with a bake that is out of this world.
And the star of her
"Twinkle, Twinkle" pie scene
will be a curry-filled globe
made with thin sheets
of delicate filo pastry,
a risky gamble,
given its notoriously delicate nature.
-[Prue] Tell us about the globe.
-The globe's going to be made out of filo.
-Filo pastry?
-[Maxy] Yeah.
You're going make filo pastry?
-[Prue] By yourself?
-Yeah.
That's a bit of a feat
to make a filo pastry.
You need to harness this.
You struggled with time
the last couple of weeks.
You need to bring it back,
get focused on this
as quickly as possible.
-Thank you.
-[Paul] Thank you.
-Good luck.
-Thank you.
Recognise my ambition here
'cause I'm making filo,
which is a bit tricky.
So I'm starting off with ice cream.
Whilst I'm doing that,
I'm also doing the savoury pastry.
[Noel] His leather trousers are made
out of rough puff pastry.
-[Matt] Wow!
-See the food colouring a bit there?
[laughs]
Chicken rendang,
which is my favourite classic food
that I love to cook all the time.
I've tried the spiciness level
on week three, the judges can handle it.
Is it very spicy?
So I've got onion, mustard, parsley.
I'm going to put some pepper.
There's already salt in it.
[Matt] Janusz has decided to dedicate
his bake to man's best friend.
[Janusz] My sausage dog's name is Nigel.
Sausage dog pie
will be a sausage dog, sausage log.
No, he's gonna be not sausage dog meat.
It's gonna be sausage meat. [laughs]
[Matt] Janusz is hoping the judges
will lap up his unique take
on The Very Hungry Caterpillar,
consisting of a picnic scene
with an elaborate decorative tree,
and each pie shaped
to represent its contents.
Have you made a lot of food
inspired by your dog?
I haven't made any food
inspired by my dog.
This is the first one.
Will he watch this?
You got a message for Nigel?
Well, he's going to be even on TV.
Nigel, if you're watching,
woof-woof, woof, woof-woof-woof.
Aw. He's going to appreciate this.
Yeah. Get off that sofa.
Never. [chuckles]
[Matt] Whilst Janusz has opted
for a canine twist to his tale,
Sandro's going for a more
traditional approach to the story.
So my 3D story is based
on The Very Hungry Caterpillar,
er, which I've read
to the kids I was working with.
[Matt] Sandro's pulling out
all the stops with two side dishes
and a staggering selection
of meat and fruit pies,
each one individually shaped
to depict both the caterpillar
and his daily diet.
In the story, are those all
the things that the caterpillar eats?
And more, yes. And he eats a lot more.
I've got about 16 pies altogether.
Oh, my goodness.
You're overdoing it, Sandro.
-Yes. [laughs]
-But what kind of pastry?
The pastry, well,
I don't know the name of the pastry.
But it's done with flour and water.
-[Prue] Right.
-Pastry dough.
Just flour and water?
-And some seasonings and butter.
-All right.
-I think we'd better leave.
-Absolutely.
-Good luck, Sandro.
-Thank you. Thank you.
Bakers, you are halfway through!
Was that too much?
-[laughs]
-I need to hurry up.
[chuckles nervously]
[Matt] With eight pies to make and bake…
[Sandro] Ice cream cone.
Let me get that baking now
since the oven is free.
[Matt] …the bakers must juggle
the complex production line of pastries.
[Janusz] I've got fillings ready,
pastries ready.
I'm gonna start baking
my pies in a moment.
[Matt] And with varying fillings,
timings and temperatures,
it's no mean feat.
My little stars.
So ideally, I'd like to begin
with the cases of my fruit tart.
I'm rushing. [chuckles]
Page four of 15. Haven't done
the pears yet, chorizo's done.
So now tree castle, still on castle.
[Matt] And while most are going
for the methodical approach…
Er, I forgot to put my
bay leaf in there. [groans]
…Maxy is freestyling.
I should've popped this in earlier.
Might've put too much cloves in there.
[sighs] I didn't work this out properly.
I don't know if I'm burning my rice.
I've forgotten quite a few
important things.
-[Matt] With fillings made and chilled…
-[Sandro] Allow that to thicken.
[Matt] …the bakers must
now shape and assemble their pies.
The apple pies, so bake them,
shape them, bake them, shape them.
There's my apple.
[Abdul] So this is the large boat,
basically, that I'm making right now.
[Sandro] This is going to be cherry pie,
which is very quick to make.
This will go in the oven to bake.
Have some cherries and paprika.
See what that's like.
That's what you're doing,
cherries and paprika?
Yeah. I'll get it ready, one sec.
[Noel] Is this a thing,
or have you just made this up?
-No, they're gonna eat it. [laughs]
-[exhales]
I have paprika sometimes on baked beans.
-[both laugh]
-That's how classy I am.
God. Mmm.
-It's good. Are you just mucking about?
-Yeah.
-Oh, is it not what you're going to do?
-No.
My eyes feel fizzy.
My liver is doing something
it's never done before.
-A reaction.
-Sort of turning around.
[imitates whirring, laughs]
[Maxy] Just need this to cool.
You don't want it to affect the pie.
Not to be too soggy.
Jack gonna taste a very rustic boy,
with rendang filling, his little legs,
pants, now Jack is a decent boy.
Bakers, you have one hour left.
-Oh, gosh.
-[Sandro] This might well completely fail.
Okay, in it goes.
[Matt] With multiple pastries
going into the oven at different times,
the bakers are feeling the heat.
[Sandro] Right now I'm multitasking.
Er, mixed spice with the apples.
Oh, I was reading the wrong bit. Okay.
I'm looking-- Wait, I'm missing a plum.
I don't even know, they all might--
They're all muddled up now.
[Matt] The bakers need to create
a three-dimensional scene
that looks spectacular from all angles.
We have the octopus legs coming out,
I'm going to poke these in the filling,
so it's gonna be standing up.
[Matt] Imaginative and intricate
decoration is required.
This is my treetop.
That's Noel's head underneath.
I asked him for help, he helped.
I'm making crème pat
to go over my fruits in my cups.
[Sandro] This is the ice cream cone.
[Janusz] Now it's just decorating,
putting them all together.
Would you like some cheeses?
[Abdul] I'm not on schedule.
[Matt imitating a pirate]
Arr, me hearties.
Arr. [laughs]
Would you have liked
to have been a pirate in days gone by?
That must have been crazy. No way, man.
It was so much blood-shedding.
You wouldn't have wanted
to make someone walk the plank?
-Er, no, not really. No.
-Not even Paul Hollywood?
[laughs] No.
-Good way to get rid of him.
-[laughs]
[Janusz in sing-song voice] The dog
will be there for half an hour.
[in normal voice] And those,
eight, ten minutes.
[sighs] Okay. Filo pastry for the globe.
I don't have a watch, you?
-I ain't got a watch. Yes.
-Shall we make it up?
-What you reckon?
-Half hour?
Half hour.
Bakers, you've got half an hour left.
Slowly everything is going in.
Only 30 minutes left.
This is crazy, man.
Putting a layer of spinach in,
'cause Mum always cooked spinach,
so I just thought,
might as well put it in my pie.
Then it's rice. I'm running out of time.
Oh, they're starting to
pop and crack a bit.
I'm going to give my fish pie
one more minute,
-because they always say my pastry is raw.
-[beeping]
[Maxy] So I'm covering cracks up
with some land.
Ideally, I would have wanted
to go a bit thinner.
[Sandro] I'm making a pear,
but I think it's gone pear-shaped.
But I don't have time.
My pastry is breaking.
[Abdul] Oh, it needs a bit more time.
Cooked. Ow. Cooked.
[Sandro] Ahhh!
[Maxy] My little stars.
[Janusz] Come on, sausage dog, bake.
Gotta make the neatest one the face.
Then I'll try and hide the cracks.
And they smell delicious.
[grunts softly]
Don't know how to put the giant together.
It's too big of a giant.
I'll take it as a giant is sitting now.
Bad, bad giant.
I've still got a bake in the oven.
These are meant to be clouds.
I don't know if they look like clouds.
Nope, it wouldn't stick.
I might need to settle
with only one beanstalk now.
[Janusz] Add a little bit of glitter
to make my fish fishy.
Some of them I have painted,
so that's good.
Bakers, you have five minutes left.
[Maxy] I think it's baked.
[Janusz] Come on. Oh, you look cute.
Ahhh! That's hot.
Bakers, your time is up.
Please step away from your bakes.
[exhales]
-Yay, it's all done. Oh, my God.
-[Maxy laughing]
It's so ugly. [chuckling]
-[exhales]
-So glad it's finished.
Oh, we've done it.
[Matt] After four hours making
their showstopper pie scenes
with a place in the semifinal at stake,
the bakers now face
the judgement of Paul and Prue.
Janusz, would you bring up
your showstopper, please?
Janusz, you could have made the fish…
-[Matt] Yeah.
-…more obviously defined.
If you hadn't told me it was a fish,
I wouldn't have known.
[Paul] Salmon's beautifully cooked.
Pastry is all right.
I mean, it could be a little bit flakier
'cause it's mainly one big lump of salmon.
-This is sausage meat in the dog's head?
-Yes.
Personally I don't like
gaps in between there.
You'd fill that with a gelatine.
Basically, this is a sausage roll.
Sausage meat is nice.
-It's all a bit dry.
-[Prue] Hmm.
-Now this one is…
-Dauphinoise.
[Paul] The pastry's nice, packed out.
As you cut into it, it's solid.
-Mmm.
-[Paul] It's a nice eat.
-[Prue] On to pudding.
-[Janusz] This is apple.
It's lovely.
It's a bit dry inside that.
That apple mixture should be
wetter than that.
I think your flavours are good.
I think the interaction with the crust
and the interior
is where it fails slightly.
It needed another element,
to wet that mixture down inside.
-[Prue] Thanks, Janusz.
-Thank you.
[Paul] Overall it's effective.
It's pretty good. You can see what it is.
-A bit rough and ready.
-[chuckles]
[Prue] So this is the chana dal.
Aubergine curry with chana dal.
I think the flavour is amazing.
The aubergine in the curry is spectacular.
Really tasty.
Let's look at this crumble.
I love that. Just delicious.
[Paul] Pastry's nice and short.
It's nice and thin, it's crispy.
Overall, I think you've done a good job,
surprisingly how simple that is.
-Thanks.
-[Prue] Thanks, Abdul.
[Paul] Well done.
It looks quite attractive.
Erm, you've had a bit of issues
with it cracking here, haven't you?
-Yeah.
-[Prue] That's a lot of pie filling.
-I like the flavour.
-Okay.
[Prue] The pastry's sort of lost
because it's a bit soft.
It's very dry inside.
It's like a sandwich, not a pie.
[Prue] The bottom of it is just raw.
Let's look at these cherry.
Tough as old boots.
-Did you make the ice cream?
-I did.
Shame it wasn't an ice cream competition.
-[laughs]
-That's really nice.
Overall, you've lost
your way with this pastry.
Okay.
[Paul] The star really, for me,
the stars at the moment.
The half globe has lost
its way a little bit.
-Start with these?
-Yeah.
[Paul] I like the taste.
I think it needed something with it
because as it's cooled,
it's turned into a pâté.
-[Prue] Right.
-[Paul] The globe.
I would've baked that filo for longer.
Want that flake in a filo.
I think filo was
the wrong choice for that.
This is the cloud.
[Paul] Beautifully baked.
It's a nice short pastry
to go with a creamy top.
If I've got one complaint, I think
the ratio of fruit to cream
is a bit wrong.
You need more fruit and less cream.
But otherwise it's perfect.
Thank you.
[whispers] Class.
[imperceptible]
[Paul] It's clever using this pastry.
Thank you.
Because it's bulletproof
and you can't go wrong.
-Very, very good.
-That's lovely.
Flaky, falls apart,
buttery on the fingers.
The filling is spicy,
but still moist and somehow luscious.
It's a real treat.
Unctuous.
Unctuous. That's the word.
[Paul] This is your other pie?
Chicken rendang pie.
Pastry thin. Thin, thin.
Filling is well-packed.
It's a nice-looking pie.
Mmm, chicken is delicious.
And it's all been kept
inside a very neat parcel.
If I had any quarrel with it,
it is a little dry.
-[Paul] Well done. Thank you.
-[Matt] Well done.
Thank you.
[Syabira laughs]
[whispers] Well done.
I've got mixed emotions. I think I got
a mixture of good and bad comments.
Erm…
I just hope I've done enough to save me.
[Sandro] The ambition was something
that definitely worked against me.
But they liked my ice cream. [laughing]
I feel a little bit traumatised
because it's the quarter-final.
You want it to be amazing
and it just wasn't quite--
It was really disappointing.
Three out of five of them,
pastry wasn't very good.
And all their pies were too dry inside.
-[Paul] Syabira's was good, clever.
-[Prue] Yeah.
Good choice of pastry. When you got into
the pie, it's a beautiful curry inside.
And also Abdul's pastry was beautiful.
The aubergine curry was fantastic.
When you look at Janusz's,
actually they looked great,
but where he lost it
is not necessarily his flavours.
-They were all quite dry.
-Yeah.
-And big gaps between pie and filling.
-Too much air.
[Paul] Maxy, I loved her chicken.
Then you looked at the filo half globe.
The filo wasn't good.
Overall, she struggled,
and she's not the only one to struggle.
Sandro, really bad.
The actual pie itself wasn't baked enough,
it was quite raw inside.
What he should've done
is a smaller thinner caterpillar.
I know it's a hungry caterpillar,
but it could've been smaller.
Yeah. I'm quite disappointed.
In line for going home…
I think obviously Maxy
and for me obviously Sandro.
Bakers, luckily for me this week,
I have the lovely job
of announcing Star Baker.
And the person
who is Star Baker this week is…
Syabira.
Well done.
We're attached to all of you,
and we don't want
to say goodbye to anyone here,
but I am afraid we do have to say goodbye.
So, erm, I'm sorry to say
the person leaving us this week is…
Maxy.
[sighs deeply] Gosh.
I told you guys. [chuckles]
[Paul] Well done, Maxy.
-You've done really well. Really well.
-[Prue] Oh, Maxy.
You've been so brilliant honestly.
I can't believe it.
I had a bad, bad week.
I knew it. I knew it was me.
I knew it was coming,
but I was hoping
my showstopper would save me.
You got through to the quarter-finals.
-[Maxy] I know.
-That's a big thing.
It's really sad to go, but I'm happy
and I am proud that I made it this far.
-[Prue] You're a lucky boy.
-I know. Yes, I am.
[exhales]
Couldn't be happier. I've still
got a chance to get to the finals.
I'm through to the semifinals.
How weird is that? [chuckling]
Stay calm.
Just go ahead
and give it my best again and then hope.
[softly] Please don't cry.
I'm trying not to cry.
Maxy's leaving.
Ah, sad, best buddy. [chuckles]
[Sandro] Don't know
if she can cry or laugh.
-She's like, she's a mix.
-She's torn.
I'm sorry. I feel so confused.
I don't know if I want to be happy or cry.
[sniffles]
[Paul] It's sad to lose Maxy.
She's been one of the strongest
bakers coming into today.
It was very close between Sandro and Maxy.
Sandro's really got to watch it now.
Next week is a clean slate.
I have to fight for the spot
to be in the final,
which is a dream for me.
[closing theme music playing]